all right there is the cap space
available to teams this year
even with the reduction from 198.2 down
to 180 2.5
plenty of teams with plenty of space the
question is who will splurge who will
spend we know the patriots won't
that would be highly out of character
the colts it's out of character for them
too they don't jump into it with both
feet right away
they did last year do the trade and the
big contract for
the force buckner but they typically
don't go chase big name free agents who
make it
through to the open market i'm
fascinated chris by the jacksonville
jaguars urban meyer
his first year in the nfl a lot of money
to spend
a team that's trying to to inject
excitement
and will it it's like it wants to will
itself into becoming a contender
right in one of the lesser divisions in
football you just have to wonder do they
have a plan that
consists of going out there and
consciously spending could that be a
shaq barrett
destination as they tried to rebuild a
defense that was championship caliber
three years ago but has gradually been
decimated well i mean we saw
you know some some commitment as the
franchise
left tackle right cam robinson they do
that so they keep him but i would think
yes
i mean if you want to get the trevor
lawrence urban meyer era
underway in a positive fashion and
create some excitement
and then more importantly like we've
talked about it many times
you know where we've seen some teams
really succeed and some teams really
have issues with this you get a young
quarterback put the support around them
start going all in on that to make sure
you justify your number one pick
in the nfl draft you know that smooth
smooths over a lot of nonsense that can
be talked about
in the media when your team doesn't do
well and things like that so i'm with
you
jacksonville is going to be interesting
of course the jets are going to be
interesting too with all the money they
have to
spend the patriots you mentioned them
they're it's week two and week three
when free agency starts for them
i'll say this you look at the cults
what what the cults you look at their
football team and go
what what else do we need they're kind
of up with depth
is this the year ballard makes some
splash moves
you know they had they got to forrest
buckner no i don't think they were you
know i know but i wonder like you know
going back to your
pass rush thing a little bit that we
talked about you know uh
last last segment you know maybe they're
one of the teams that go out there and
try to get one of these guys to
you know not a huge like gigantic
contract
but somebody to come off the edge they
had
issues getting to the quarterback with
just their front four last year
buckner got there he was annoying but
everybody else was just
okay and that to me when i look at them
and go
whoa all right they got a carson wentz
they're in the super bowl window
and you just go they need a pass rushing
difference maker upset
up front and maybe that left tackle for
anthony castanzo right other than that
so where maybe they do make some splash
moves here this year mike
i know it's not usually ballard's thing
or just
or bargain shop or password maybe
because there's just so many of them and
both of their guys both of their
starters from last year
on that list i read earlier denise autry
and justin houston
so they they definitely have needs at
the position but there are plenty of
guys out there
peter king has a look at some of the big
contracts that have been given out in
recent years and typically
it doesn't work typically it it's not a
great
football move it can be a great business
move and you know let's face it there
are mandatory spending
requirements there's a certain amount of
cap space you have to use and
and there is a motivation from a
business perspective to create
excitement to get season ticket renewals
to create the impression
you're trying to win a super bowl every
team says every year
our goal is to win the super bowl
because they have to say that because
they need to have the fan base engaged
and that's what every fan base wants
they don't just want to play off
appearance they want the whole thing
so you've got to do that sometimes and i
think there can be a disconnect in some
organizations between
what's good for football and what's good
for business and the teams that have the
best and most functional football
operation are the ones who ignore the
temptation the pressure the urging of
the business people
to go out and play fantasy football yeah
but with 32 nfl teams chris
there's always going to be somebody who
plays fantasy football
whether it's the jaguars this year or
some other team
we're gonna see it there's gonna be a
handful of guys maybe not as many as
usual
but a handful of guys that make a ton of
money on the first day but by the time
we do this tomorrow morning
what's the over under four and a half
four and a half guys
who are going to have contracts that we
say wow
four and a half you're taking the over
you're taking the answer well that was
that that
was literally going to be my next
question to you because that that's
where i am
like fascinated by about what we might
see here is this going to be a year
where there's less splash signings
and teams kind of sit back and wait and
kind of get a feel for the market a
little bit
with you know the reduced salary cap and
some of those type of issues like
i'll i'll take the over of four and a
half
but i don't think it's much past that
you know what what do we see usually i
feel like last year we saw a lot more
than four and a half right i mean it
seemed like last year it was like
it was a whirlwind of of things
right yeah bam i'm two for two last
month but yeah explosivity
a whirlwind of things there like as far
as what we
what we saw in free agent signings and
everything like that
so i i don't know mike what's your pasta
and meatballs got to tell you
what do you think peter king and i were
talking about this over the weekend i
think he makes this point in football
morning in america
27 guys were last year
under under contract or it agreed to
terms the first day
last year so i i think it's gonna be
less than 10 more than five peter
targets
six guys that he thinks will get good
money this week not necessarily this day
dalvin tomlinson the giants defensive
tackle shaq barrett guy we've talked
about
lions receiver kenny galladay steelers
receiver judy smith schuster
trent williams who we've talked about
joe tooney the patriots guard who was
franchise tagged last year no doubt
titans tight end john ooh smith those
are the six names yeah that peter king
identifies seven names one two three
four five six
seven names that he's identified uh as
guys who could get good money this week
so i'll go over four and a half but not
by much
less than 10 more than five that's what
i'm going yeah i would agree though
those are some names that
we i discussed on my podcast recently
too and yeah dalvin tomlinson's one of
those guys where most people like
the really common casual fan might go
what but he is
the best interior run stopper
run stuffer double teams all those type
of he's going to be one of those guys
this week i think that like signs as a
defensive tackle somewhere
everybody's going to go or a lot of
people are going to go wait who he got
what how much money
uh you know the giants i don't think can
keep him they got a lot of big people
and yeah he's one of those guys that can
help out a run defense in big ways
also don't rule out the possibility of
trades today last year on this day the
first day of the
legal tampering period there were three
headlined by
the move that signaled the beginning of
the end for the houston texans
decision to trade deandre hopkins to the
cardinals because you want to get these
deals done because if you're not going
to fill your needs with a trade
you're going to fill your needs in free
agency so trades
can and likely will happen today we saw
a couple yesterday
marcus cannon from the patriots the
texans right shaq
lawson and bernard mckinney a couple of
linebackers flip-flopped by the texans
and the dolphins not the texans dolphins
trade that
we all want to see hoping for but who
knows maybe that could happen hey
hey we're here we're here to serve the
interest and the needs of the nfl
consumer
you never know what's going to happen hi
i'm mike tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports